the fnatic continuing to try and uh take
control of bento tati's junior
[Music]
he does not want an autograph he's
brought the police officer over he's
been trying to get tatis away from the
fence fernando has spent an incredible
amount of time with folks before every
one of these games
in philly and just signing for as many
kids as he possibly can and the fnatic i
think a little bit jealous of the
attention he is and uh who would not
want a fernando tati senior autograph on
your jersey the fanatic should get one
because he's going to be a star for a
long long time ah the valley who the
tomfoolery of the fanatic it never gets
old
vince velazquez the 29 year old making
his 13th start for sema curveball
change-up slider and a two-seamer
making his fourth career start fifth
appearance against the potteries and if
you remember his first start against
them one of the best of his career one
of the best as far as affiliate is
concerned as well
with nine innings three hits shutout
ball no walks he struck out 16. here is
tatis 301 average 26 home runs 2-2 liz
wong on well hit the left field going
back is mccutcheon he's racing to his
left he's not going to get to it it's
going to bounce and carry him off the
wall mccutcheon finally gets to it but
not before fernando is cruising easily
into second base
with a one out double 17th double on the
season for fernando tatis jr a little
two strike damage tony that'll bring up
manny machado who hit a first inning
home run yesterday for the padres only
runs of the day
and on the ninth pitch
manny sends one to deep center field
again williams going back at the wall
gonna go
machado into the trees with a second
consecutive first inning and the padres
lead at two to nothing number 14 on the
ninth pitch of the attack flake snow 28
year old making a 16th start he's had 11
days rest how will he come out of this
he's got a two spot working for him he
needs a quick in as andrew mccutchen one
for six of the series let's see if the
phillies can capitalize today as they
did yesterday in the dirt mccutchen just
said take a look there's the foot on the
hit the toe no no
here so it stands he is still in the box
a little tapper back to the mound snell
fires to second for one over to first in
time depending on if he was indeed hit
that was a fairly painful at-bat for him
that'll bring up their third baseman
alec bome hitting 238 four home runs 35
rbis
1-0 pitch swung on popped up on the
infield that's gonna be the first
baseman eric hosmer calling for it and
he lets it fall and he's gonna throw it
to first base as the runner at first was
not going they're going to try to get
the double play the runner at first
remains
boom who popped it up is out
so eric hosmer trying to do the old drop
the infield pop-up trick to try to turn
the double play since reece hoskins was
not running on the pop-up the umpires
are conferring it looks like what was
called will stand and hoskins will be
aboard palm is out now manny machado
with the two-run missile out to center
field and his first at-bat gets a crack
out runners scoring position 0-2 on
manny
and machado hits it in the air to deep
left field he has done it again
a three-run shot in the third and a
five-to-nothing padre lead that is
clearly out of the zone
manny gets to it and sends it on its way
two g's in swag two homers for manny it
has been the manny machado show here
today reebos is coming up he hit it to a
double play as last time
oh
fortunately wayne kirby got in the way
and now profile is getting on him
that'll make the highlight reel
bouncer left side they can still turn
two even though this isn't hit that hard
there's one and two whoa
aggressive all the way around you see
the clap of the hand by segora because i
think he thought baum was just gonna go
to first base
good feed
and then the electric throw by segura
kirby coming back to the dugout and he
heard it from everybody
i mean look look they're like can't you
just move a little bit
oh man he got us a double play cost us a
run yeah
i mean they are on him barajas hosmer
caratini
maddie machado was on him two on with
one out you got to take advantage here
well here's luke williams the one-two
swung on a miss strike three
he went back to the slider again
williams swinging over the top of it two
away
hard hit but right at fernando tatis jr
and the inning is over so snell works
around both walks and the philly's still
off the board so the intentional walk to
machado loads the bases up for grisham
over to first base
that's a fair ball according to the
first base up fire three unassisted
the intentional walk leads to the final
out andrew mccutchen oh for one he
walked his last time up hit into a
double play in the first and that is a
hard hit grounder to manny could it be
six
it is unbelievable double plays across
the board today for both teams andrew
mccutchen uh our philly of the week
heading over to uh his spot in left
field looks like he did something to his
side i hope he's okay philly's down five
to nothing they need some offense
down the right field line for real
mutual going back on it is pro far it is
gone
and the phillies are on the board
so the home run for jt
it's his eighth of the year five one
game top of the order gene segura segora
is one for two
ground ball shark way to third oh my
goodness how about this how about four
double plays
maddie machado has been busy over at
third five four three
another side is retired three bosses
over three a couple double plays in the
strikeout
over to third off the glove of miller
picked up by terrain as the throw in
time what a play
pinball and around the infield to reyes
kept his eye on the ball and there are
two outs that's amazing right man right
spot how about the athleticism for the
reyes on that play
i mean seriously amazing yeah
talk about instincts and heads up and
being in the game on every play
that'll load the bases for eric hosmer
reads four and a fair ball down the left
field line coronal worth has scored
manny is on his way grisham will be on
his way
and the relay not in time a basis
clearing double for eric cosmer as the
padres extend their lead eight to one i
think mccutchen is heading in he tried
and i think he tried hard i think that
throw just did it 2-0 on rivas
and he hits it a ton out to deep left
field
nearest grooved him one and he didn't
miss it a three run homer and an 11-1
lead in the night second in the big
leagues for webster rivas
third home run of the day for the padres
and this inning
a three run double and a three run homer
there have been seven ground ball double
plays in this game phillies have hit
into four
and that is in the air out to left
center field
and grisham lays out to make the catch
out number two as hoskins hustles back
to first
that's gold glove defense
by trent grisham and center we are one
out away
reach sport and kind of poked out to
shallow center trent coming in
he makes the catch and the padres
get this fourth of july special in
philadelphia
three and three rain soaked trip but all
smiles for manny and friends